this video was sponsored by
curiositystream
watch thousands of great documentaries
and the early ad-free and extended
version of videos like this one
on nebula for just 15 bucks a year
2017 was an especially turbulent year
for north korea
even by its already aggressive standards
in february kim jong-un's older
half-brother kim jong-nam
was assassinated in malaysia during the
summer
it accomplished its long-awaited nuclear
goal of firing an intercontinental
ballistic missile
capable of reaching the us mainland with
this new firepower
it threatened to attack the american
territory guam
which the u.s countered with its own
threat of war
the u.n security council passed more
severe sanctions
and the u.s re-added north korea to its
state sponsors of terrorism list
joining iran sudan in syria nine years
after being removed
then in early 2018 tensions began
de-escalating the world sighed a deep
breath of relief
as north korea agreed to send athletes
to the south korean winter olympic games
one of a series of actions intended to
signal its goodwill
and although this cycle of rising
tensions followed by diplomatic charm
was both familiar and expected there was
real hope
that this time because north korea had
finally achieved its nuclear security
guarantee
it would genuinely be motivated to make
and stick to a deal
kim jong-un personally invited donald
trump to a meeting
then director of the cia mike pompeo
secretly flew to pyongyang for
preliminary arrangements
and after several near cancellations
both sides agreed to a summit
this would be the first ever meeting
between a sitting american
and north korean leader the decision to
meet however
was only the first in a long chain of
private negotiations which would take
place in the weeks leading up to the
event
and would significantly impact its
outcome
one such important detail was the
location of this historic meeting
which in many ways would set the tone of
everything to come
initially five places were rumored to be
in consideration
u.s officials mentioned vietnam thailand
switzerland sweden and singapore
specifically
at first glance all of these choices
seem like strong candidates
and the case could easily be made for
each of them
sweden for example was the first western
nation to establish an embassy in
pyongyang
who it has maintained unusually strong
diplomatic ties with
the us which does not have an embassy in
north korea
frequently works with and through the
swedish embassy acting as an
intermediary
switzerland where kim jong-un received
his childhood education
was also a prime contender europe
however
had a natural disadvantage and that it's
simply too
far between taking office and that point
in time
kim had visited only two countries china
and south korea
on three trips during which he was at
most
only 700 kilometers or 400 miles from
his home country
another option mongolia was within reach
of kim jong-un's state plane or armored
train
but lacked the infrastructure necessary
to confidently guarantee
a smooth-running event most importantly
though the choice of location could not
be seen as a concession by either side
indeed even holding the event would
already be perceived by some
as legitimizing the rule of kim jong-un
therefore
the u.s side would likely not agree to
pyongyang
beijing or russia the search was
narrowed between either near the joint
security area on the demilitarized zone
or singapore the latter of which ticked
all the boxes and then some
and was finally agreed upon strangely
the small island city-state is
considered friendly territory by both
sides
and would even be approved of by other
interested parties like china
russia and japan this on its own
is remarkable that a nearby asian
country would have no direct stake or
interest in the dispute beyond a
peaceful resolution
even more so that a country in the
region would have strong diplomatic
relations with both north korea
and the united states simultaneously
singapore hosts a north korean embassy
traded a small number of goods with
pyongyang before sanctions were
tightened
and amazingly allowed north korean
passport holders visa free entry until
2016.
practically speaking it could also
guarantee a summit without interruptions
protests are allowed without police
permission only in a single
area of one public park called the
speaker's corner
a kim jong-un impersonator in fact was
detained and questioned after arriving
from australia
these same legal features which lead
some visitors to call singapore
boring were precisely what made it so
attractive despite being relatively far
for kim and the event going incredibly
smoothly
on june 10th at 8 20 pm air force one
landed at the jointly operated u.s and
singapore air force
paya labar air base kim on the other
hand
arrived earlier that afternoon at
singapore's main international airport
before touring the downtown area in the
evening
a sign of just how safe the young
dictator felt
the singaporean government meanwhile was
not merely an observer
it held high-level meetings with both
presidents paid for the north korean
accommodation
and released an official logo for the
event promoting its reputation
as a trusted neutral third-party
facilitator
this image has been carefully crafted
over decades
it also hosts the annual shangri-la
dialogue and rotating summits of the
association of southeast asian nations
in 2015 singapore was chosen for the no
less historic or delicate meeting
between chairman xi jinping
of the people's republic of china and
then president of the republic of china
or taiwan mayang cho that event was so
sensitive in nature that even the
linguistic terms used were carefully
scrutinized
because neither side recognizes the
legitimacy of the other
officials negotiated their respective
titles in advance
they would be addressed as the leader of
mainland china
and leader of taiwan and refer to each
other
only as mr and mandarin here too
singapore is unusual and that it
carefully engages both sides of this
heated geopolitical divide
its military has trained with taiwan
since the 70s
and is the only southeast asian country
to share with it a bilateral free trade
agreement
singapore's long-standing almost default
status as a trusted intermediary makes
it easy to forget
just how unlikely this fact is
having been forced into independence by
its expulsion from the federation of
malaysia
in 1965 the new republic faced several
potentially existential threats
at about 700 square kilometers or 270
square miles
singapore is about one-fourth the size
of rhode island
has no large lakes or rivers is devoid
of natural resources
and is now home to around five and a
half million people
not only is it not predisposed to
project global power and relevance but
its small size and close proximity to
much larger malaysia
and indonesia make even its continued
existence
challenging and because of its strategic
location on the strait of malacca
it even faces threats from non-state
actors like
pirates these undesirable circumstances
impressed on its early government the
urgent necessity of making
and keeping as many friends as possible
from those early days of independence
singapore positioned itself as the
switzerland of asia
engaging with anyone who would accept
its friendship
but while swiss neutrality is
deliberately static
and unchanging singapore attempts to
balance the relative
influence of its powerful allies china
and the united states
in addition to being its largest source
of foreign investment
the u.s is also a significant military
partner
when the american military was ordered
to leave the philippines in the 90s
singapore allowed it access to its
changi naval base
one of only a few piers in asia deep
enough for u.s aircraft carriers to dock
and resupply
american nuclear submarines aircraft
carrier groups
and spy planes regularly transit through
singapore
on their way to conduct freedom of
navigation exercises in the south china
sea
this military cooperation agreement was
renewed for the second time in 2020
and in another sign of its strong ties
the us
also sold singapore 12 f-35 fighter jets
but while it engages with the us very
closely
it does not do so exclusively singapore
is careful
never to choose sides for example
it never officially refers to the u.s as
an ally
and uses the term american facilities
not bases
likewise it abstains from discussing
sensitive issues in
china including its controversial
maritime claims
singapore conducts military trading
exercises with the people's liberation
army and china is its largest trading
partner
realistically neither china nor the us
likely appreciate its close relations
with the other
and occasionally attempt to tilt the
balance in their favor
when singapore is tested however it
almost always remains disciplined
in its neutrality for example in 2003 it
turned down an offer to become an
official non-nato ally to the us
and in 2016 china impounded nine of its
armored military vehicles
in hong kong on their return journey
from training in taiwan
a clear reminder of its influence for
the most part
both sides appreciate the predictability
of this strategy
which has survived three singaporean
prime ministers
and ten american presidents six of which
were republican
and four democratic for decades
singapore has greatly benefited from the
economic
rise of china while not being beholden
to it
thanks to its close military engagement
with the us
in not being forced to choose sides it's
benefited from both
but as china has grown in size and
influence
deteriorating its relations with the us
singapore
has remained small the close personal
relationship of its founder
lee kuan yew with china's leadership is
no more
and once again it must fight to survive
as the peaceful stability which enabled
its prosperity
is replaced with more aggressive
relations between its two
non-ally allies the cost of neutrality
will only grow in other words one day
singapore may finally be forced to
choose a side
but until that day comes it would like
for both sides to fear
the outcome singapore's natural
dependence on other countries
has led it to pursue some unusual
policies to ensure
its security for example the singaporean
government has convinced its population
to drink pea humorous as that sounds
it's absolutely not a joke to find out
what drinking pee
has to do with singapore's national
security you can watch the extended
version of this video which replaces
this ad
on our new streaming platform nebula
while these videos will continue being
available
here there are some topics and tangents
like
drinking pee that aren't quite right for
youtube but i just can't not mention
if you enjoy these videos the best way
to watch them
is before they're posted on youtube
without ads
and with specially made bonus content
from your favorite creators like
wendover productions
real engineering and rely floor on
nebula
but it gets better because we've
partnered with curiositystream where you
can watch documentaries like singapore's
field of dreams
which explains how the city built a
stadium which can adapt to hold over 30
different sports
and the rise of the gulf about the
growth of oil cities like dubai
you can get curiosity stream and nebula
for the very affordable price of just 15
bucks
a year in other words you get access to
thousands of great documentaries
you get ad-free early and bonus content
you help support creators like myself
and right now it's 26 off
it would be a crime not to take
advantage of this deal
sign up with the link in the description
and you'll get an email shortly
afterward with access to nebula